you
the briefing will now begin at 10 45.
um
hey
10250
last night we concluded a meeting with
senator schumer
and uh speaker pelosi uh a little bit
before ten o'clock
and uh at the president's direction
we have made no less than four different
offers to
democrats on capitol hill on how we can
make sure that the enhanced unemployment
that is set to expire today
along with eviction protection
that is set to inspire as well
is protected and those four different
offers uh have been
uh actually rejected
but more importantly than that uh
they've not even been countered with a
proposal
so the democrats are certainly
willing today to allow some of the
american citizens who are struggling the
most under this
pandemic to go unprotected and
the president has been very clear for us
to be uh
aggressive and forward-leaning to make
sure that they get protected
and yet what we're seeing is politics as
usual
from democrats up on capitol hill uh
it surprises me that uh when we talk
about compassion and caring about those
that
that truly uh are in need
uh that a temporary solution
to make sure that unemployment enhanced
unemployment
continues has been rejected not once but
multiple times
the democrats believe that they have uh
all the cards on their side and they're
willing to play those cards
at the expense of those that are hurting
and
we'll continue on with additional
discussions today with
senator schumer and senator uh in
speaker pelosi
uh perhaps an in-person meeting tomorrow
on capitol hill
as we we stay engaged but i'm
i'm disappointed in uh uh
and what we've found from our democrat
negotiators
is that they are bumping the price
higher than the very bill
that they passed out of the house
several weeks ago
and to give you a particular example of
that is
in their heroes bill they have a hundred
billion dollars
for schools we
match that offer and actually put a
fourth a proposal for a hundred and five
billion
dollars for schools for k-12 and higher
uh institutions
and yet what did they say to that oh no
that was two months ago
we want to increase the the the amount
of money that we send to schools
to 400 billion dollars we're going in
the wrong direction
they're going in the wrong direction
because of partisan politics
it is very disappointing and so we call
on capitol hill to
get serious about their negotiations the
president is serious about the
negotiations
we're willing to engage as you know
leader mcconnell yesterday put forth
a one-week extension at the current
levels for enhanced unemployment
and what did we see senator schumer
objected to that
so there's no clear message that the
american people should receive
other than the fact that the democrats
are willing to pay
play politics at a critical time in our
nation's
uh very dire circumstances as we deal
with this pandemic so
i wanted to give you that brief update
so that you could have it uh straight
from
uh the negotiations as they've happened
uh over the last three days and uh as we
work i'm gonna
i'm gonna turn it over to uh to the
the press uh secretary and i think she's
prepared to answer all the questions
liability insurance is that a deadline
for you guys mcconnell said it was
thank you guys i think she'll address
that the
um i'll take your questions in just a
moment the chief has to run to
a meeting but earlier this week i just
wanted to start off with an overview of
what we've been doing on kovid the
president
rather president trump visited the great
state of north carolina to highlight the
important work being done as part of
operation warp speed and thanks to
president trump's leadership the trump
administration has made substantial
investments
including investing in multiple vaccine
candidates with several entering phase
three clinical trials including
astrazeneca moderna and pfizer providing
financial infrastructure for mass
manufacturing of potential vaccines
guaranteeing doses of a vaccine will be
available for distribution
shortly after approval the race for a
coronavirus
vaccine is truly moving at warp speed
under
president trump in addition president
trump is leading on therapeutics over
140 clinical trials are now underway
rem deciver dexamethasone convalescent
plasma
and monoclonal antibody treatments
yesterday president trump visited the
american red cross headquarters to hold
a round table on donating plasma
this initiative will empower americans
to help their fellow americans
and battling the virus these critical
investments in a coronavirus vaccine are
due to the fact that we have a
businessman in the white house
and according to the wall street journal
quote democrats blame the us case surge
on an adequate testing and contact
tracing but the us has averaged
two to three times more tests per capita
than most european
and asian countries indeed we've done
more than 59
million tests with india at number two
with just about 14 million tests so
quite a difference there
arizona california florida and texas all
were doing more tests per capita when
they lifted their lockdowns more per
capita than germany spain france and
south korea
have averaged the us is the undisputed
world
leader in testing um and on top of the
more than
59 million tests that we've done the fda
has authorized more than 193 tests under
emergency use authorizations
including molecular antibody tests under
the leadership of president trump the us
is leading the world and safe and
effective therapeutics and the rapid
development
of a potential vaccine together as one
american people
we will defeat the invisible enemy and
with that i will take questions
paula thank you on mark's mark's
comments about how
it's democrats who won't compromise
democrats came up with a plan
two months ago the republican plan was
just presented on monday and in that
time the president has contradicted
the republican plan on the amount of
stimulus checks on student loans
mitch mcconnell threw you guys under the
bus on funding for the fbi building what
do you say to the tens of millions of
people
who are going to lose their benefits
when it appears that the real issue
is that republicans cannot agree among
themselves even though they've had
months
that's not it at all in fact democrats
offered a three trillion dollar plan
uh we have a very specific focus right
now
i mean it's not this comprehensive plan
whether it be the heroes act the
democrats propose
that was on sirius or the heels act that
narrow focus is this
that americans are about to lose their
unemployment insurance
and this white house this chief of staff
this president this
secretary of the treasury have offered
several iterations to make sure
that americans who through no fault of
their own lost their jobs during this
pandemic do not also
lose these checks we've made several
proposals as
mark meadows just said to you and how
many proposals have the democrats
made zero and if if you want to know
where the democrats um true intentions
lie
look no further than the martha mcsally
bill that was presented that would have
extended
the 600 unemployment insurance it was
rejected
by chuck schumer and that was a plan
that the president was willing to
endorse white house
what do you say to those that are going
to lose 600 a week in
unemployment uh payments that need that
money
and also uh why didn't you start
negotiating earlier and why only the
offer of an extension of one week
what would i what i would say to them is
that this is unacceptable that the
democrats have been fundamentally
unserious and
uh the you just heard the chief of staff
say a great example of that is they had
this massive three trillion dollar bill
that called for
100 billion in school funding we then
gave 105 billion which then was
deemed insufficient so if democrats were
interested
in extending unemployment insurance and
helping the american people
they would have endorsed the martha
mcsally bill and extended
this by a week to give us time as we try
to extend this in perpetuity while we
also focus on evictions
what what do you say to those americans
that are about to lose 600 a week that
they need to be calling the offices of
chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi and say get to work and
stop engaging in politics on the backs
of hard-working americans
who deserve these checks who lost their
jobs through no fault of their own are
you keeping the pass on the liability
protection
um that's a that's a question for mitch
mcconnell he said that that's going to
be a part of any bill
but that's mitch mcconnell's uh that's
his priority
um this president is very keenly focused
on unemployment insurance and the martha
mcsally bill is a great example of what
democrats are focused on
yes kaley if the president is so worried
about how long it'll take to count
ballots in the election then why isn't
the president and this white house doing
everything it can to secure
more funding for staffing
and other resources to make sure that we
can have a safe and proper election
look what this white house is focused on
um is making sure that
our election is not riddled uh with
voting fraud
and that the timetable is not hung up
here um
we are there are several lawsuits that
the campaign is engaged on and i would
point you to the campaign for specifics
answer my question though my question is
what is the white house doing to get
more resources for funding and staff to
make sure as the president says
that it will be a secure and safe
election well as you know peter states
run their elections
um and it is up to states to make sure
that they have the capacity
but what this white house is focused on
is ensuring that
um what jeffrey toobin has said over at
the new yorker cnn contributor notably
new york's primary vote count chaos
signals trouble
for november and as he noted you want to
talk about the president but jeffrey
toobin himself
democrats control the state government
of new york they are responsible
for creating the fiasco that is
unfolding now and that is certain to get
worse in november states need to get
their acts together
um when it comes to uh elections and as
we see in new york where we're five
weeks out from that election
uh and in fact we still don't know the
outcome of a congressional race and that
is certainly not what we want to see
i'm asking you about the president you
asked why i was asking about the
president i'm asking about the president
because you work for the president i
guess the question is
more specific thank you kaylee um so the
president is leaving this morning
a few minutes with the national
association of police organizations um
in 2008 2012 they supported barack obama
and joe biden
in 2016 they didn't support either
candidate and now in 2020 they're
endorsing president trump
uh to what does the white house
attribute this change in support
well it's clearly a change in the
democrat party uh jen when you look at
the polling on defunding the police abc
news ipsis poll 64 opposed defunding the
police
huffington post 57 opposed rasmussen
59 opposed but make no mistakes
democrats
want to defund our law and law
enforcement and comes at a time where 64
of americans say they are concerned that
growing criticism
of america's police will lead to a
shortage of police officers
and reduce public safety in the
community where they live uh
the american people have seen very
clearly uh where the democrat party of
today stands it's at an unacceptable
place
and i think that this administration has
shown great respect for our law
enforcement
who every day are out there defending
and protecting our streets and
democrat-run cities
that have turned abundantly chaotic
because of their lack
of support and respect for law
enforcement darlene
can you explain why the white house did
not counter with a comprehensive plan of
its own you see
the white house was focused on two
things the unemployment insurance and
evictions
why not why not have a more
comprehensive proposal to counter what
the democrats have put on this so i've
walked through at this podium
uh the more comprehensive plan that this
white house i was hoping to see in our
priorities like tax rebates
unemployment benefits um enhanced hiring
and retention payroll credits workplace
tax credits restaurant donations and
others
those are all part of the the heels act
so there is a comprehensive plan that
was put forward by republicans on the
hill with several
white house priorities in it but right
now at this day
at this moment our focus is making sure
that americans who have lost their jobs
get their paychecks it's why as you
heard the chief of staff
say we've made four proposals democrats
have made precisely
zero nomination of general tata is the
white house still behind that
uh the president still uh supports
general tata yes
haley so is there anything that that you
agree with on the democrats after
all these negotiations are there any
points of unity so far
well look they've they've presented zero
plans so we've presented four they've
presented zero so
do we agree with them it seems that they
don't agree with us the white house
supports unemployment insurance benefits
the white house supports ensuring
americans don't get evicted
but what do the democrats support what
do they stand for so far they've offered
zero nothing except rejecting martha
mcsally's bill to ensure
uh that that those who are receiving
those checks continue receiving them
upper limit really for the amount that
you're willing to go to is the white
house decided on some sort of a cap for
how much you're willing to spend
this round not that i'm aware of the
president i has said you know he wants
to make sure
money gets to the american people the
trump administration wants 377 million
dollars in the coronavirus really built
for
the um the long-delayed modernization
of the west wing how is that a priority
in terms of the coronavirus pandemic
you guys talk about priorities you have
the fbi bill which
doesn't seem to have much support from
capitol hill as well so uh two things
and i'm glad you asked that because i i
do want to um
give you some details about those two
items in particular um when it comes to
the fbi building this has been a long
discussed
issue i would note that the three
previous covid bills that have been
passed had plenty of other things in
them that were not related to coving one
of those examples is the
harbor maintenance trust fund this is
not a red line for us
it was a part of the initial bill but it
is certainly not a red line the priority
as i've said
several times so far is unemployment
insurance
making sure americans do not get evicted
and then
as it pertains to white house
renovations many of those
pertain to safety protocols filtration
systems
enhance community communication ability
um and needs that we saw that were
highlighted
during the pandemic but make no mistake
you know a 377 million dollar proposal
will not stand in the way of ensuring
that the american people
get their checks that is the priority
i'm ensuring that americans do not get
evicted
that is our our number one number two
goals
thank you kaylee i just wanted to
confirm reports that mark meadows
actually made an offer to extend
unemployment insurance by four months i
have not i
haven't spoken him on that precise
proposal but as he's mentioned there
were four that were made
wrote to twitter's ceo asking him to
remove tweets from iran's supreme leader
ayatollah khamenei calling for the
genocide of the israeli people
the company refused to do that because
they said that the tweets were quote
comments on current affairs i'm
wondering
if the white house has a response given
that twitter has recently begun
restricting
the president's own tweets for
glorifying violence
quote glorifying violence and spreading
this information and if you have spoken
to the president about
any further action perhaps he's taking
on social media companies
yeah it's a great question ebony i did
see that new york post story
and i thought it was very eye-opening
and it tells you where the social media
company stands where they're not
willing to uh to to assess the ayatollah
khomeini's tweets um but they are
willing to assess president trump's
tweets it's really appalling and it just
speaks to their overwhelming
blind bias against conservatives and
against this president
and we are taking action the
administration is submitting a petition
to the fcc
for proposed regulatory changes to hold
social media companies accountable for
their censorship
um and this petition that was previously
reported on
earlier in the week asked the fcc to end
the loophole that allows social media
companies to escape civil
lawsuits for their own speech fact
checks and d
platforming and the petition seeks to
expose social media companies
to liability as a speaker or a publisher
if they act as editors of content on
their platforms or remove lawful speech
based on politics and very good work by
the new york post
and highlighting that issue yeah can i
follow up on darlene's question
on tada for a minute you said that the
administration is still behind him but
is you guys considering putting him in
an acting role i have no personnel
announcements other to say than the
president still supports him
thank you it's been a month since the
reports of
russian bounties on american military
forces and yet
the white house has done nothing to push
back on putin
what is the what is the delay so as i've
answered probably a dozen times from
this podium that intelligence
is unverified there are dissenting
opinions on the
media is uh i would point to the
department of defense saying there's no
corroborating evidence to validate
recent allegations and i see allegations
in recent press articles have not been
verified
or substantiated by the intelligence
community and odni is a similar
statement
but look this president acts he is not
afraid
to stand up to russia he's done so
repeatedly when our adversaries
have directly targeted u.s or coalition
coalition
partners the president did not hesitate
to act look at syria
in 2018 when dozens of russian
mercenaries were killed in a retaliat
retaliatory defensive strike um he has
continually stood up to russia will
continue to do so
and this president will always protect
our troops and our men and women
overseas
i mean he will act on verified
intelligence
thank you ma'am um so colorado hawaii
oregon utah and washington all have
automatic
mainland ballot systems the white house
has made its position clear on absentee
ballots and also the concern
over these universal systems
does the white house think that those
elections are fraudulent or more at risk
always a mail and ballot system mass
mail out ballots
um are going to be more at risk of fraud
look at la county where
112 of la county is registered
that means you have 12 percent of excess
ballots floating around
uh that are we know at least 12 percent
uh that that are that are not accurate
ballots that were mailed out
um this is a very basic concept and it's
one that the media has done a very good
job reporting on not just geoffrey tubin
at the new yorker you also had the
washington post article on this that the
president held up yesterday
that says the results um that they that
they've seen
in a study of showed that there's an
unexpected stress test of male 1
balloting systems many of which were
designed to handle only a small portion
of the vote
and are not ready to scale up in
response to a pandemic that was
washington post
there was another great abc piece male
and voting delays in primary cause
pennsylvania to sound alarm about
november
expansion of mail and voting will likely
delay the state's presidential race a
great cbs report
pennsylvania's mail-in votes still
weren't all tallied up after one week
officials fear election nightmare
in november so mass mail and voting uh
certainly subject to fraud
and good work on the part of abc cbs
washington post and the new yorker for
highlighting the fraud that is at play
the delays that are at play
uh because those are after all the facts
another quick one uh
the chief sounded quite frustrated a
second ago is there
any situation in which the white house
would walk away from negotiations on
phase four
i won't get in the middle of the
negotiations and i'll i'll leave that um
to the chief
and to the secretary of treasury um but
yeah there's a there's a lot of passion
because
we're passionate about making sure
americans are taken care of i've heard
the president personally talk about this
it is it is his goal to make sure uh
that those who have lost their job get
these payments
um and those who through no fault of
their own um do not get evicted from
their home so those again
two big priorities for the president um
raquel
yes thank you so much i have two
questions one
you were here saying that uh how well
the administration is doing is
responding to different
but the facts don't show that and
americans are struggling and scary how
do you what do you tell them
american people so the one thing i would
say is um the president's made clear
that we're at a place um where
we want all americans to make sure that
they socially distance
um and that they make sure they engage
in mitigation tactics
um and uh the president's been been
clear on that
um but you know one of the things i
think as when you look at the united
states response you look at
the fact that we were supposed to have a
ventilator shortage in fact we had a
ventilator
surplus we were we were told that there
was a testing shortage well it turns out
we've done at this point almost 60
million tests uh this president-led on
the
development of remdessevier we just saw
this week promising signs from
convalescent plasma
our therapy
particular at the case fatality rate
which the president often talks about
you see that that tells that tells a big
story when the u.s case fatality rate
is at 3.4 percent the world's is at four
percent
average in the eu at 9.7 percent that is
a testament to our therapeutics
um but we encourage every american to
engage in mitigation efforts
um and it's patriotic as the president
said to wear a mask
especially when you can't socially
distance that's another question
i'm a travel dancer yes there is a
movement drawing called
love is not tourism they they are
families and couples separate for a
month
because of the travel ban couples who
couldn't be together
on their child birth or mother
themselves or
separated during illness they are asking
if the administration could consider
a waiver in their cases um i haven't
spoken to the president about those
specific cases
but this president will always put
america first this president
put in place the travel bans to protect
american lives and they've done that dr
fauci acknowledging that
the travel bans have saved american
lives and that that is our goal at this
moment hunter
thank you kaylee uh two quick questions
for you um herman cain passed away
yesterday and obviously he had tested
positive for covid
nine days after attending the
president's rally in tulsa officials
there have connected the rally to a
spike in cases
is there any concern that herman cain
may have contracted
uh frontavirus at the president's rally
and is the task force doing any
follow-up to track other potential
cases from that event look herman cain
is the absolute embodiment of the
american dream
we are grieved and we are very saddened
by his passing he was raised
our party um and i i would refer you
to a post on herman cain's website and
he says i realize
or his website rather i realize people
will speculate about the tulsa rally but
herman did a lot of traveling the past
week
i don't think there's any way to trace
this to one specific contact that caused
the infection
um we'll never know um so that and
i will not politicize um herman cain's
passing and i would just note the
great contributions he's made to our
society will always remember him and his
legacy will stand
and then just follow up on another point
um obviously the president's tweet um
yesterday seemed to float the idea of
delaney election
he later said you know he supports no
date change whatsoever
given a little bit of the ambiguity and
confusion there can you just state
unequivocally um whether or not the
white house wants to see the date
changed
and states 100 that that is not
something that you support
the president answered this three times
yesterday he said i want the date more
than anyone i don't want to delay i want
to have the election and then a
local interview he did he said no one
wants the date of the election more than
me
uh because he believes november third
will be a moment where the american
people
acknowledge the great successes of this
administration yes
okay thank you does the president
support the chinese-backed hong kong
government
in delaying their elections yeah so i do
have an answer
for you on the hong kong elections we
condemn the hong kong government's
decision to postpone for one year its
legislative council elections and to
disqualify
opposition candidates this action
undermines the democratic processes and
freedoms that have
underpin hong kong's prosperity and this
is only the most recent and a growing
list of broken
promises by beijing which promised
autonomy and freedoms to the hong kong
people
until 2047 and the sino-british joint
declaration
i think it's appropriate as we see this
play out on the hill
um this uh testimony by our doctors to
just acknowledge
the real successes um and and work of
this administration i acknowledge the
ventilators
and i talked about testing and just
great american industry coming together
the american people coming together
and working to get us through on this
tragic pandemic
and we we grieve when even one life is
lost
but i do want to point out just the
early actions of this administration
when there were zero reported cases in
the united states on january 6
the cdc issued wuhan travel notice
before
any u.s confirmed cases um but what were
pelosi and chuck schumer doing they were
calling on the gop
to support bolton testifying zero
reported cases in the united states on
january 17th the cdc
implements public health entry
screenings at three major u.s
airports receiving the greatest volume
of wuhan passengers
what were democrats doing oh house
democrats were preparing to file their
first brief in the impeachment
sham impeachment inquiry when there was
one reported case
in the united states on january 21st cdc
activated emergency operations center
what were democrats doing oh chuck
schumer was calling for witnesses in the
impeachment trial and pelosi released a
statement
criticizing mitch mcconnell for his
trial rules and
finally when there were seven reported
cases in the united states on january
31st president trump issued travel
restrictions
on china and the first mandatory
quarantine in more than
50 years and those travel restrictions
saved
american lives but what were democrats
doing
pelosi was introducing the no ban act
which would have imposed
undue limitations on the president's
authority to restrict entry of aliens
into the united states and what are
chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi doing now stopping
americans from getting their
unemployment insurance
and it's despicable and it's time for
them to come to the negotiating table
thank you very much